>> Tucker: WELL, THE BACKLASH
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
BROADENING IN SCOPE FOR ABOUT
LEGEND STAN LEE.
HE'S 95 YEARS OLD.
AT THAT AGE HE NEEDS NURSES TO
CARE FOR HIM AT HIS HOME.
NOW SOME OF THOSE NURSES HAVE
ACCUSED HIM OF GROPING THEM AND
ASKING FOR SEXUAL FAVORS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS APPALLING
OF COURSE.
HARASSMENT WAS FIRST COINED.
HELPLESS ELDERLY MAN DOES SEEM
LIKE PREYING ON THE WEAK NOT
PROTECTING THEM.
WHAT ARE WE TO MAKE OF THIS?
ASHLEY PRATT JOINS TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
RARE CASES -- I DON'T KNOW THE
TRUTH OF IT.
IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME IF IT
WERE TRUE.
THE ELDERLY, FOR A BUNCH OF
PHYSICAL REASONS, SOMETIMES DO
I MEAN, THEY DO.
THIS IS A WELL KNOWN PHENOMENON.
MOST NURSES WHO CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY ARE AWARE OF THIS.
SO GIVEN THAT, IT SEEMS A LITTLE
CHARGES AGAINST THE GUY.
IT IS KIND OF COMIC.
>> WELL AT THE SAME TIME THOUGH
WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS A LITTLE
SERIOUSLY AND REALIZE WHEN THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE COMING OUT,
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS.
WE CAN'T JUST GO OUT THERE
DEFAMING PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES THAT I HAVE
CURRENTLY WITH THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT.
IT'S DOING A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS, BUT IT IS ALSO ALLOWING
A PLATFORM FOR DEFAMATION TO
HAPPEN.
IN THIS CASE, IF THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE, THEN IT
SHOULD BE BROUGHT IN A LEGAL
SUIT AND THEY SHOULD BE EXAMINED
FOR WHAT THEY ARE.
IF HE WAS GROPING PEOPLE AND HE
WAS EXPOSING HIMSELF AND DOING
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT THEY
ARE ALLEGING, THEN THAT IS
DESPICABLE BEHAVIOR.
BUT IF, IN FACT, IT'S JUST JOKES
AND WHATNOT, WE CAN DETERMINE
A CAMPAIGN WITH ALL MEN MULTIPLE
TIMES.
I KNOW JOKES VERSUS
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
I THINK WE NEED TO TRUST WOMEN
IS AN ISSUE.
>> Tucker: WHAT IF THERE'S A
THIRD EXPLANATION WHICH -- I
DON'T KNOW THE TRUTH, BUT HAVING
BEEN AROUND THE ELDERLY.
I THINK EVERYONE WHO HAS KNOWS
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT IF THEY'RE TRUE, BUT A
SYMPTOM OF ADVANCED AGE?
THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON.
SO IS THERE AN AGE OF WHICH,
MAYBE IT'S 95, WHERE WE SAY,
DONE WHEN YOU WERE 75 OR 55.
>> WE CAN MAKE EXCUSES.
IF HE'S EXPOSING HIMSELF AND ASK
WHEN THEY CAME OUT WITH THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST GEORGE W.
BUSH, THAT BOTHERED ME.
THOSE WERE JOKES BEING MADE IN
FRONT OF HIS WIFE.
YOU CAN HAVE AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
WHRORPB HE SHOULD BE MAKING
THEM, BUT IT IS JUST JOKES.
IN THIS SITUATION, IF HE WAS
GROPING WOMEN WHO WERE TAKING
CARE OF HIM THAT IS A PROBLEM
YOU CAN'T BLAME ON OLD AGE.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN BLAME IT ON
OLD AGE.
>> THAT IS A BEHAVIORAL ISSUE
THAT WE SHOULD NOT TOLERATE AS
MEN OR WOMEN.
>> Tucker: I'M TOTALLY OPPOSED
TO IT, EXCEPT THERE ARE CASES --
THAT'S AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
BUT THAT IS SOMETIMES A SYMPTOM